neuroscience now tells us more about the
mind than philosophy or maybe if we
modified it might or may well or will
tell us more about mind and philosophy
in other words can neuroscience settle
philosophical debates about the mind but
let's begin at the beginning and
introduce the panel
Margaret Bowden on my left is research
professor of cognitive science at the
University of Sussex the New York Times
says she is at the forefront of efforts
to exercise Cartesian superstition
Stephen rose on my right is M emeritus
professor of Neurobiology at the Open
University and author of the making of
memory and Barry Smith on the far left
is director of the Institute of
philosophy at the School of Advanced
Study at the University of London
neuroscience can in principle and
already has in a few cases made
philosophers who are prepared to listen
think again and perhaps change some of
their views about the mind and I suppose
one of the examples of that is the
experiments on split brain where you cut
through the corpus callosum which
connects both sides of the brain and you
find that you get behavioral rather like
a split personality and you're the one
side of the body not knowing what the
other side is doing and so on and so on
so certainly I don't want to say that
even current neuroscience is irrelevant
to philosophy but I think that current
fad in neuroscience are brain scanning
brain imaging is almost totally
irrelevant and what's more not only
irrelevant to philosophy I actually
think it's of almost no scientific
interest whatsoever now I think it's
brain scanning it's mostly non
scientific fishing expeditions trying to
find correlations between psychological
events like I don't know thinking about
God for example or whatever it may be
psychological events on the one hand and
brain events on the other hand and
sometimes they appear to find such
correlations but there are two very big
butts even if they find the correlations
the first is they don't know what their
correlating in the brain because they're
getting at for example both excitatory
neurons and inhibitory neurons so
neurons that are antagonistic in their
functions so all they can say is this
part of the brain is buzzing but just
exactly what's going on that they have
no way of saying I'm not saying this
will always be true but certainly with
the current technology I think that's
true but there's a bigger but a second
part which is that these are what is
called non-scientific fishing
expeditions
they aren't driven by theory about
what's actually going on
what the brain is doing about if you
like what are the psychological
functions that the brain is is making
possible I once actually said this I
said to Chris truth who was one of the
first that in my view one of the very
very best people in in brain imaging and
I said to him well you know saving your
presence Chris I said I think 95 percent
of the brain scan staff is a complete
waste of time
in the terms about just say if he said
no no no 98 that's a true story
so I think they're doing natural history
one of these days and I don't think it's
going to be soon at all one of these
days it may be possible for people
thinking more theoretically about these
matters to fit these correlations and of
course lots of other correlations which
we will then have in much as Darwin was
able to fit in hundreds of thousands of
natural history facts which people
including himself had been collecting
for years into the theory of evolution
and make it part of the evidence and use
it scientifically
before there yet have been just natural
history so I'm not saying that true
history is a waste of time but I'm
saying it's a different matter from
science
most of mine your scientific colleagues
are actually committed to the view
indeed the mind is the brain there's a
sharp reductionist position in which
minds are to be reduced to brain nothing
but the froth or nothing but one of
Maggie's philosopher colleagues calls
folk psychology which can be replaced as
she wants to argue by the concept of a
computational brain now some of what she
said I agree with that is that the brain
in human staff is if you like I would
put it in internal phrenology that 98%
of it is irrelevant is probably true for
most of the scientific papers that are
published throughout the world today and
a lot of it is irreducible as well but
that's not the point I want to make I
want to disagree both of my nearest
scientific colleagues that the mind is
the brain and with what Maggie has Joe
has just said in relationship to the
computational brain I do not think that
either minds or brains are computational
we are not digital systems we are best
analogic systems are not computable in
the way that Maggie is talking about I
want to argue that we need our brains in
order to have minds in the same way as
we need our legs in order to walk but we
do not say our legs are walking we say I
am walking we do not say or we should
not say our brains are thinking we
should say I am thinking and using my
brain in order to think that the brain
is a necessary organ so far as thinking
so far as minding is concerned I take
completely for granted otherwise I
wouldn't be on you're a scientist I
wouldn't be trying to understand the
brain processes that go on during a
whole lot of thinking activities during
learning during memory and so on but I
do not think that the activities of
learning thinking minding and certainly
being conscious are reducible to brain
processes and let me explain why I've
already said because I because it is I
the self which is doing these activities
with our brain but I want to go further
it's not just that brains are embodied
they are located in the living
human being but bodies and brains are
embedded in the social and cultural
world in which we live and because they
are embedded in the social and cultural
world that we live the activity of
minding and here I go along with the
philosopher Gilbert Ryle who said that
you should not use minders are now but
you should use it as a verb it's an
activity minding is what is going on in
the conversations between us on the
panel in the discourse which is going on
between us and all of you and mind is
therefore a social phenomenon it's
almost a collective phenomenon our minds
are constituted by certainly by biology
certainly by our evolutionary history
certainly by the fact also that we live
in particular societies in particular
cultures in particular times that is I
do not think that the 21st century mind
is the same as the 19th century mind or
even the 20th century mind minds are
profoundly changed by the society and
the technology in which we live I'm one
of those unfortunate older people who is
not originated with a digi immigrant and
I'm quite convinced that the minds of
might not just nice as my grandchildren
would also my children who brought up in
a digital age are different from mine in
ways which are constituted both by brain
processes and both both by the social
culture and technology in which we exist
here's the worry I think for
philosophers and probably for all of us
the worry is that there are certain
things we are interested in explaining
what it's like to be conscious beings
what it's like now to see me and hear me
to be enjoying your moods and feelings
and emotions and people who are
interested in that the nature of
experience they're worried that when
they turn to neuroscience instead of
having that explained that neuroscience
might change the subject so instead of
saying you know what's it like to see a
familiar face it'll just tell you about
the workings of the visual system and
how we recognize movement and color and
we detect change so there's this worry
that when you turn to neuroscience if
you are asking a philosophical question
you might be changing the subject now
here's the heresy from my point of view
we need to change the subject because
quite often philosophers are starting
with common-sense ideas that are wrong
misleading so for example in the field
that I work we started off taking our
theories of perception and the way we
explore the world is based on the idea
that we have five senses why do we think
we have five senses we got far more than
that I mean just just for one just think
you've got a sense of balance without
that your experience will be very
different now Aristotle gave us the talk
of five senses and it's been preserved
alive but if you ask neuroscientists how
many senses have we got they say
anywhere between 22 and 33 well we've
come across
[Applause]